The joe rogan experience
be new year. Tom. Papa.
Yeah. Happy you get. Thank you
for the gift. You're welcome.
I've always wondered one of these.
It's amazing. Really. It is.
I got two things that I
really don't want today.
One was herpes. No. Yeezys
you'll love him Jamie. Thanks. I'll love.
He got me the party here and I said,
take these back. These
are yours. You keep him.
And He came back and
brought me the right size.
He insists first he brought me to
the Bronx. What's wrong with them?
They're fucking preposterous.
Let me see him.
If you're um, Brendan Schaub, they're
the perfect thing because they're in,
this looks like something
from the nineties yeah,
like some kind of shoe from the 90s now
what level of outrage would there be if
I started wearing these
to run the mountains?
What if they were really comfortable and
you liked them? I know what's going on.
So you think that if I put them on,
I would all of a sudden loved them and
I would get it. Those are street maybe.
Are Those for the street?
Does he have like a bird?
He'll have like a extra hook
in the back of the heel? Yeah.
Like why is it go like a normal heel?
Like here's a normal heels, right?
Those flat flush,
it's flat.
It's like goes out at an angle on
those two. That does too. Is the boost.
It's the style of shoe. It's the bottom.
It's what it's part of the Adidas.
Is it the style or is it the uh,
the shape?
Is it the style or is it the feel that
you really like the feel but won't? Both.
Honestly, both. But these
were really comfortable shoes.
The boosters are super comfortable. Is
this a Adidas made shoe? Is that, yep. Oh,
so Didas makes the, yeah. And
there's just no Adidas logo on there.
So it's hard to tell that he's starting
to like them starting to warm up while I
weird how they have this like
military style number. Yup.
Thing on the side.
Like some fucking Korean missile
quit. Is there, I couldn't tell you
what it stands for. I've seen it.
Multiple things. It could just be
supply or couldn't you come up?
It could be an acronym for
something. I don't, yeah,
they look like they're from the nineties
enjoy them.
Thank you,
sir.
Okay.